you declared bankruptcy too twice twice
at had a year in your early 90s where I
had 0 income and is this true where you
were working a desk job answering phones
and people would recognize you asking
you aren't you D Snider and you would
have to lie yeah I couldn't sell my
catalog I would have given it away I
would have sold it for 10 $220,000 I was
broke I had three children so somehow
during the 80s my wife asked me to write
a Christmas song and I wrote a Christmas
song not a rock song cut two late ' 90s
I get a call the engineer who was in the
studio recording that song with me it
tells me Selene Dion wants to record my
wife's Christmas song that record is the
biggest selling holiday album of all
time 14 million copies it's called These
are special times you own the publishing
to that yeah hell yeah that was the only
song I never wrote for commercial
release and it may be the most valuable
song I've ever wrote wow